[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Hello, everyone.
Today we'll be taking a
look at how light interacts
with the surface
of a solar cell.
Right now I'm standing next
to a solar module made up
of individual
silicon solar cells.
If you look closely, these
cells actually appear black.
And they appear black for
a very important reason.
Solar engineers work very hard
to make their solar cells as
efficient as possible.
Reflected light is lost
energy, so good engineers
will want to minimize the total
amount of reflected light.
To make solar cells absorb
as much light as possible,
and appear black, solar
engineers do two things.
First, they grow
this very thin film
of a dielectric
layer on the surface.
This layer is aptly called
an anti-reflection coating.
Second, they texture the wafer.
And today we'll demonstrate
how texturing is performed,
and quantify its enhancement
for reducing light reflection.
Silicon wafers don't
start out black.
In fact, they appear gray.
Polished wafers even
look mirror-like,
and reflect quite
a bit of light.
Here we see a polished wafer,
which reflects around 1/3
of the light off its surface.
And to create the rough surface
that reflects less light,
solar engineers immerse
their silicon wafers
into a hot, wet
chemical bath, which
helps create tiny
surface features.
In this example,
we use a solution
of potassium hydroxide,
or KOH, which
is heated to around
80 degrees Celsius.
This violent
reaction is actually
etching into the
silicon, and carving out
little tiny pyramids
on the surface.
And the result is a wafer that
loses its shiny appearance,
and appears to
have a dull finish.
The textured wafer is
left with a surface that
is covered with microscopic
pyramids, whose base
is around a micron,
or about 1/50
of the width of a human hair.
It turns out that this wafer
only reflects about 1/3
as much light as
it previously did.
The reason this KOH which
bath work so well at texturing
the silicon surface
is due to the fact
that these silicon wafers
are large crystals, which
in this case means that the
atoms are formed in an ordered,
repeating pattern.
I have a model of the silicon
crystal structure right here.
On our model, I've highlighted
the surface in red.
Note that each silicon
atom below the surface
is actually bonded to
four other silicon atoms,
with four covalent bonds.
Note that the surface
atoms are only
bonded to two other
silicon atoms,
and it has two bonds
that are unbonded.
The alkaline etch is able
to remove silicon atoms more
rapidly, when they have fewer
bonds holding to the lattice.
Hence, a solution quickly
removes atoms on the surface.
Now if I were acting
as the KOH solution,
I would remove
all the atoms that
only have two covalent bonds.
Let's remove a few atoms.
So this one only has
two covalent bonds.
It gets removed.
These three atoms
on the surface only
have two covalent
bonds holding them,
so I'll remove them as well.
Let's go ahead.
Now we can see that after
we have removed a few atoms,
we have created some atoms below
our original surface that only
have two covalent bonds
holding to the lattice.
These atoms will also
get removed by the KOH.
Now if we continue
this process, it
would look something like this.
So what we're going to do
is measure the reflectivity
of both a flat and
a textured wafer.
First, we'll measure
the flat wafer,
and use a laser pointer
as a light source
to simulate sunlight coming
from very far away point.
We'll shine light
down on the surface,
and measure the
amount of light that
gets reflected or
bounced back away
from the surface,
which we'll label as R.
So I'm standing next to our
first experiment, which I just
outlined in the previous sketch.
We'll be using
this laser pointer,
shining it onto this silicon
wafer, and into our photodiode.
For those of you who don't
know what a photodiode is,
it is a tool that can
measure the amount of light
hitting its surface.
The current that's read
off of this ammeter
will be proportional
to the amount of light
hitting our photodiode.
To help visualize the beam path,
we're going to use some steam.
Now if we turn on our laser
pointer, hits our photodiode,
and we can get a good reading.
And right now we see that it's
reading around 0.9 milliamps.
But how does this compare
to a textured wafer?
Let's find out.
Now it's hard to
measure the reflectivity
of a textured wafer
with a laser pointer,
because it bounces the light
off at several different angles,
and we can't measure the entire
beam with a photodiode alone.
However, we can simulate
what this would be like.
Let's go to our
sketch board to show
how we can approximate
this measurement.
To measure the reflectivity
of a textured surface,
we'll create a 10,000
to one scale model.
We'll approximate
our textured surface
using two pieces of silicon.
Again, we use a laser
pointer as our light source,
and shine it on one
side of the pyramid.
It'll bounce off that
next surface, and off
the adjacent side,
and then we'll
measure the amount
of light reflected.
Let's go to our
experimental setup.
So let's clarify our set up.
The two angled lines in our
drawing, the adjacent sides,
on our atomic models, and the
two angled, non-textured wafers
in our set up, are all
representing the pyramid
structure of a
textured wafer, just
like the one visible in our
scanning electron microscope
image.
Let's use some steam to
visualize the beam path.
Now that the steam
has settled, we
can get an accurate
reading of the reflectivity
of our modeled silicon surface.
And I turn on our laser pointer.
So now we can see
that our photodiode
is reading around
0.33 milliamps.
This corresponds to
around a 9% reflectivity,
which is quite a huge
reduction from what
we had before, by
about a factor of 3.
So in summary,
today we learned how
silicon is etched
using a KOH solution,
and how the resultant
pyramids increase
the efficiency of
our solar cells,
by reducing the amount
of reflective losses
by a factor of 3.
If you found this
interesting, please
watch our other solar
demos to learn more about
how these exciting devices work.
I'm Joe Sullivan from MIT,
and thanks for watching.
I'm out of here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]